there are few historical nations which
capture the imagination
as much as prussia with its staunch
militarism its dedication to phenomenal
facial hair and its iconic borders
yet if you look at a modern map you'll
see that there's a distinct lack of
pressure
but why what happened to it and where
did prussia go now i know what many of
you will already be saying
prussia just became germany right which
is both true and also isn't
you see prussia wasn't just a
nation-state but it was a cultural
center a major part of the
german-speaking world and briefly an
international great power whose
influence stretched far beyond its own
borders
prussia's journey from firmly existing
to not isn't a linear one and this
change starts in the mid 19th century
in 1866 due to a conflict surrounding
the ownership of some land recently
taken from denmark prussia went to war
with the austrian empire and its allies
it promptly defeated them and as a
result the prussian chancellor otto von
bismarck annexed the northern austrian
allies and forced its own to join the
north german confederation
which wasn't really a unified nation
state but more of an alliance completely
dominated by prussia the north german
confederation didn't last too long
because if you look at the time you'll
see
it's time for war with france and in
this war the prussians were on the same
side as the southern german states who
came to its aid
and after defeating the french army the
victors proclaimed the creation of the
german empire and for many this is where
prussia ceases to exist
except that it didn't the german empire
as the name suggests was an empire and
it consisted of several kingdoms duchies
and principalities all of whom were
considered to be semi-independent
barring matters of collective defense
that is the emperor of this new germany
was also the king of prussia and the
empire's chancellor was automatically
the prime minister of prussia ii
despite prussia's dominance of the new
german state it shouldn't be seen as
prussia simply becoming the german
empire and as having annexed the other
parts
they were all separate in the same way
that hungary and austria were separate
in the austro-hungarian empire
like all empires the german one didn't
last forever and after world war one it
was dissolved lost a bunch of territory
and was succeeded by the weimar republic
much like the rest of the empire
prussia lost its royal team became the
free state of prussia minus these lands
and it was now governed by its own diet
now obviously prussia still existed but
it was very changed and no longer
reflected what it's historically famous
for
for one it was one of the more stable
parts of the troubled weimar republic
for example its state government was
nearly always run by otto brown of the
social democratic party which brought it
into conflict in the late 1920s with the
conservative german chancellor and the
central government
to fix this the german chancellor franz
von papen and president hindenburg
issued a decree in 1932 simply
dissolving the prussian state government
and von papen was now directly in charge
of the state he
didn't last and neither did the weimar
republic and its replacement maintain
direct control over prussia
the new government reformed germany's
internal states into new units called
gao in 1934
and this was basically the end of
prussia as a single territorial unit but
there were some titles and traditions
which remained
along came world war ii and as you know
germany lost this one too
as the country was being occupied otto
brown approached the allies and asked
them to reinstate prussia as an
independent state
the allies said no because by this point
they'd already decided to take this land
from germany
and also there were many in the allies
that felt that german militarism came
from the legacy of prussia
and they believed that ending prussia's
very existence after a lost war would
kill the cultural roots of militarism in
the new germany that was to come about
afterwards
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly money maker the
pastry section marvin cassell rob
waterhouse moe
aaron the white james castaneda danny
maloney jordan longley marcus arsenault
gustav swan jerry lambton john bailey
spinning three plates
rasheed ali cooling castleman david
silverman izzy
coppertone maggie paxkowski winston
cayward lexy schwinn spencer lightfoot
robert wedzill fortunate calf anthony
beckett and skye chappelle